007 himself it's mr daniel gray
yeah that's a pretty suave entrance mr
bond but are you ready for the royal
family how do you get used to it i don't
know tuesday was the london premiere for
no time to die daniel craig's final
outing as double07
and the guest list featured some
familiar faces from buckingham palace
let's take a look at the night's royal
encounters
there's prince william kate middleton
prince charles and his wife camilla
making their way to meet the stars at
royal albert hall first up we've got
craig shaking hands with the prince of
wales
perhaps thanking him for saving the
country so many times over the years
and is it just us or is kate thrilled to
be talking to the iconic secret agent
you can imagine why i've come back to
play well anna de armas wasn't hiding
her excitement when she met kate's
husband either
meanwhile rami malik gave us full well
rami malik and is that prince charles
getting a laugh from phoebe waller
bridge
i mean it's everything you can dream of
in so many ways billy eilish and brother
slash collaborator phineas also made it
across the pond
[Music]
billy sings the movie's theme song no
time to die which the siblings co-wrote
we can't wait for the bond song one word
to describe
bond i don't know okay it's gonna be fun
daniel craig's final time playing james
bond in no time to die hits theaters
october 8th
the royals night out follows an eventful
weekend for prince harry and meghan
markle
speaking at global citizen live on
saturday it was the couple's first
public appearance since daughter
lillabet's birth in june
and while in this country and many
others you can go almost anywhere and
get vaccinated billions of people around
the world cannot
william and harry continue to have a
strained relationship and it remains
unclear where or when we'll see the
brothers reconcile so what is the
situation between harry and william now
what's their relationship like the
relationship between harry and william
is still very much one of distance and i
don't just mean physical across the
atlantic but they just aren't talking
that much you know that's exactly how
sources close
to william have put it you know there is
still some feelings of anger there over
the way in which the couple
sort of carried out their departure from
their royal lives and you know i think
for william that's something that he
clearly hasn't been able to come to
terms with yet
they are very different men and i think
william
has certainly become someone that is
really living his life for the crown for
the institution now and harry has really
sort of bucked that and gone in
completely the opposite direction so
you can see how they'll never see eye to
eye and unless both sides can
acknowledge that they'll never move
forward